voilà là il y a bien devenu
tétraplégique à l'âge de 20 ans Samuel
Marie n'a jamais perdu son goût pour les
voyages et c'est un défi hors du commun
qu'il souhaite relever en effet avec son
opération Sam me fait rouler il souhaite
traverser les États-Unis l'Europe et
l'Asie et pour réaliser son rêve il
s'entraîne depuis 2 ans je suis tous les
jours sur mon petit vélo pour pouvoir
aussi me développer au niveau musculaire
etc le corps il tienne parce que c'est
des corps un petit peu fragiles la
ttraapégie c'est pour ça que les
personnes avant moi l'ont pas fait parce
que c'est un petit peu compliqué à
mettre en place et je vais être je vais
être aidé par un kiné à distance aussi
qui m'aidera aussi sur les sur certaines
douleurs et tout ça pour m'accompagner
donc voilà il y a un kiné qui passe
quatre fois par par semaine chez moi qui
m'aide aussi pour pour ça et il y a
muscu renforcement du vélo et je fais
pas mal de de sport autour pour
traverser ces 16 pays Samuel sera au
volant d'une camionnette d'une valeur de
130000 € qui pourra répondre à tous ses
besoins et son projet intéresse Lambert
traoras le PDG de la start-up girolift
c'est un soutien dans un premier temps
de je dirais logistique c'était de
réseau partage de réseau de connexion et
puis à terme lorsque nos nos deux
start-ups se se rejoignront c'est
pourquoi pas fournir un un girolif pour
que pour ces prochaines aventures et en
fait ça mais la vitrine de ces
personnesl l'objectif c'est c'est de
rendre le girolift adapté à tout type de
handicap et donc et donc d'arriver à
terme à à permettre à une personne
tétraplégique comme Samuel de pouvoir
utiliser notre nouveau fauteil roulant
pour mener à bien son Paris Sam a besoin
de 300000 € il est actuellement à la
recherche de sponsors il participera
prochainement au salon du tourisme qui
se déroule du 16 au 19 mars à Porte de
Versailles à Paris